here is Thomas Massey basically getting
accosted by New York Democrat Jamal
Bowman over the shooting and just watch
the difference in tone in content and
behavior it's rather extraordinary
school that allows teachers States
[Music]
[Applause]
I was a middle school principal I was a
cafeteria's protecting kids every day of
my career
[Music]
it's time we've got friends here to
protect us
should have somebody to protect them
every school that's allowed it has never
had a shooting not even an accidental
discharge at any of the schools there's
so much there first off I mean look the
obvious stuff like just the general
behavior of these people Jamal Bowman is
just grandstanding screaming getting in
Massey's face he he touches him a couple
times uh Massey is clearly trying to
explain something to him right he's
clearly trying to explain hey you know
and we all went through this firsthand
uh there are metal detectors when you
walk into the capitol there are armed
security guards everywhere literally
every hallway every door outside inside
everywhere now I'm actually not taking
the position that that's what we want at
every school because I do think over
time if you sort of just militarize
everything uh the the changes in
behavior for people will not be a net
good I think there's a there's a
psychological and mental component to
this that we really have to deal with
but the the general idea of of oh we all
walk around security we have metal
detectors we have people out there but
we let these schools not be guarded by
anything is clearly the right one so
there's a tone issue and that Bowman is
doing exactly what lefties do with
virtually everything it doesn't matter
if you know what you're saying if you
just stand in a big room knowing that
there's cameras there and scream a
certain amount of people think oh he has
righteous indignation so he obviously is
right
[Music]
foreign